GOOD EVENING. WE ARE CALLING THE
FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE TO ORDER.
WE WILL WAIT FOR A QUORUM TO
FOR WE HAVE A CORE.
WE WILL CALL THE ROLL.
TING.
OBERNOLTE.
ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BROWN'S.
CABALLERO.
CHáVEZ HERE CHIU.
JOINT.
COOPER.
FONG.
HARPER.
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
LACKEY HERE. LOW MOAN.
MATHIS HERE MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ.
MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI.
O'DONNELL RUBIO.
STONE.
VOEPEL.
WEBER.
WHAT?
OF COURSE PRESENT.
THANK YOU A TONIGHT WE ARE
COMPETING AS A FULL ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE TO DISCUSS THAN
APPROVE.
THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE A
PROPOSAL LITTLE TOO BUDGET
APPLES AS WE GO INTO.
BUDGET CONFERENCE COMMITTEE. OF
THE ASSEMBLY IS HE'S ASKING FOR
APPROPRIATING A HUNDRED AND NOW.
FORTY FOUR BILLION DOLLAR.
REVENUE AS WELL AS WE ARE
EXPENDING A HUNDRED AND FORTY
BILLION DOLLARS.
WE ARE SETTING ASIDE SEVENTEEN
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS INTO
TOTAL RESERVES. WHICH IS A
HISTORIC HEART. I IN ADDITION
SOME OF THE MAJOR HIGHLIGHTS
WHICH I KNOW EACH OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS WILL BE
GOING IN. A LITTLE BIT MORE
SPECIFICITY WAS APPROPRIATING A
BILLION DOLLARS FOR HEALTH CARE.
THE BULK OF THAT WAS TO EXPAND
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE BUT ALSO TO
REDUCE HEALTHCARE COSTS IN
PREMIUM COSTS FOR MIDDLE CLASS.
FAMILIES ARE STRUGGLING TO PAY
WAR OUR PURCHASE HEALTH CARE.
I IN ADDITION WE AGREED WITH THE
GOVERNOR TO FULLY FUND THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA. ó WE
DID APPROPRIATE ADDITIONAL MONEY
TO OUR INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
READ BOTH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN ADDITION TO WHAT THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED IN MAY. AS WELL AS TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS TO THEIR CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY WHICH WAS. I IN
ADDITION TO WHAT THE GOVERNOR A
PRO APPROPRIATE MAY. COME.
WE ALSO DID A VERY SIGNIFICANT
APPROPRIATIONS THE AREA OF
HOMELESSNESS AS WE ALL KNOW
HOMELESSNESS IS A CRISIS. NOT
JUST IN OUR URBAN CENTERS BUT
ALMOST IN EVERY CORNER OF
CALIFORNIA WE'VE OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND I PEOPLE WHO ON ANY
GIVEN NIGHT ARE HOMELESS HERE.
IN CALIFORNIA DONE NUMBER SEEMS
TO BE GROWING ON EVERY DAY WE
ARE PROPOSING A ONE POINT SIX.
BILLION DOLLAR EXPENDITURE TO
FIGHT.
HOMELESSNESS.
THE BULK OF THAT IS
APPROPRIATED TO.
HELP OUR CITIES FIGHT
HOMELESSNESS IN THE EMERGENCY
SITUATION WHETHER IT'S BUILDING
SHELTERS BUILDING APPLICATIONS
CENTERS ARE RENTAL ASSISTANCE OR
RAPID RE HOUSING.
IN ADDITION A COUPLE OF. OTHER
AREAS JUST TO KNOW IS WE
APPROPRIATE NINE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS TOTAL
INCLUDING A FEDERAL FUNDS INTO
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION. AYE
DAYCARE SLOTS PRESCHOOL AS WELL
AS FACILITIES.
OPERATIONS IF FACILITIES WELL
UPGRADE SO THAT THE SCHOOLS CAN
HELP BUILD IT INCREASE OUR
CAPACITY TO OFFER PRESCHOOL. ARE
IN ADDITION WE ARE WE
APPROPRIATE HUNDRED FIFTY THREE
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TOWARD.
THE CENSUS COUNT WE THINK
THAT'S EXTRAORDINARILY
IMPORTANT.
IT'S A.
STORE IT'S YOUR OWN CRITICAL
THAT EVERY CALIFORNIA GETS
COUNTED SO THAT WE CAN FIGHT FOR
THE FEDERAL DOLLARS THAT WE NEED
AS WELL AS MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
ADEQUATELY REPRESENTED IN THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES. AND
LAST WE. FOUND WE WERE HAPPY TO
SEE THE.
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL OF.
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS TO EXPAND
THE EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT
WHICH LOWERED THE.
AGE LIMIT ON WHO COULD QUALIFY
FOR THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT.
WE FELT THAT OVER THE YEARS
THAT'S BEEN ONE OF THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAYS THAT WE CAN
FIGHT.
POVERTY I DON'T FORTUNATELY WE
HAVE TOO MANY.
FOLKS LIVING IN POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA AT THE SAME TIME THAT
WE ARE NOW BECOME THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY. IN THE COUNTRY.
OUT WITHOUT A TURN OVER TO BUY A
VICE CHAIR MISTER WILL TO SEE IF
HE HAS ANY. COMMENTS.
BOB THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
WANT TO COMMEND THE WORK OF OUR
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEES OVER THE
LAST SIX MONTHS.
I THINK PEOPLE OUTSIDE THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE PROCESS DON'T
REALIZE WHAT A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF WORK IT IS TO SERVE ON THOSE
SUBCOMMITTEES.
AND I I JUST WANT TO COMMEND
ALL THE MEMBERS AND ALL THE
STAFF THAT WAS THERE TO SUPPORT
US OVER THE LAST SIX MONTHS
BECAUSE I I KNOW THAT WE'VE
WORKED VERY VERY HARD. POP.
I THINK IT IS A VERY UNUSUAL
SITUATION WE FIND OURSELVES AND
TO HOW TO SPEND A NINE BILLION
DOLLAR SURPLUS.
I THINK THAT OUT OF THE CHAIR
AND I SHARE A LOT OF THE
COMMITMENTS TO OTHER INVESTMENTS
IN INFRASTRUCTURE. NOW AND
SHORING UP THE STATE'S RESERVE
FUNDS ARE HOWEVER I I HAVE SOME
FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEMS WITH THE
BUDGET THAT WE HAVE PUT
TOGETHER.
I THINK THAT TOTHE EXTENT THAT
WE SPEND THAT SURPLUS WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE SPENDING ON
THINGS THAT ARE TRUE
INVESTMENTS.
IN CALIFORNIA AND BY INVESTMENT
I MEAN A DOLLARS THAT YOU SPEND
TODAY EQUALS LESS MONEY THAT
YOU'LL HAVE TO SPEND IN THE
FUTURE. AND I SHARE THE
GOVERNOR'S CONCERNED ABOUT
SPENDING MONEY THE CREEK CREATE
SPENDING PRESSURE IN FUTURE.
YEARS AND FOR FUTURE
LEGISLATURE'S AND I'M AFRAID
THAT WERE DOING TOO MUCH OF
THAT.
IN THIS BUDGET HIGH AND I HAVE
OF ONE KIND OF OVERRIDING
CONCERN.
AND THAT IS THAT THE CREATION OF
A THIRD. A BUDGET DEFICIT
SAVINGS ACCOUNT A THIRD RESERVE
ACCOUNT FOR.
INVESTMENT IN SORT OF SOME OF
THIS RESERVE.
WE ALREADY HAVE TO BUDGET
RESERVES ACCOUNTS THE.
THE OLD RECALL THE RAINY DAY
FUND THE BUDGET STABILIZATION
ACCOUNT AND THE SPECIAL FUND FOR
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTIES AND
ALTHOUGH THE BSA HAS A CAP THE
SFE YOU DOES NOT HAVE A CAP.
SO THE ONLY REASON TO CREATE A
THIRD TYPE OF ACCOUNT. IS IF WE
WANTED TO AVOID ON AUTOMATIC
REDUCTION IN THE STATE SALES
TAX.
THAT'S THE ONLY CONSEQUENCE OF
PUTTING MORE MONEY IN THE US AND
FOR YOU. SO THE ONLY REASON FOR
CREATING THAT THIRD ACCOUNT IS
TO AVOID GIVING THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA BREAK ON THEIR SALES
TAX AND I THINK A BRAKE IS
BECAUSE APPROPRIATE IN AN ERA
WHEN. A LOT OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
ARE STRUGGLING TO AFFORD TO LIVE
IN THE STATE THEM IN AN ERA WHEN
THE STATE HAS A NINE BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET SURPLUS SO I'M
GONNA CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE. THAT
WE FUND THE SFE YOU INSTEAD OF
CREATING A A THIRD TYPE OF
RESERVE ACCOUNT THE BDS SAY. BUT
I THINK IMMIGRANT MUCH MISTER
CHAIR.
GIVE US A VICE CHAIR. AGAIN JUST
TO ECHO THE VICE YEARS COMIC
JUST WANT TO THANK ALL THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO SAT
THROUGH HOURS AND HOURS OF
DELIBERATION. JUST WANTED TO
THANK ALL THE STAFF MEMBERS WHO
WORKED EXTRAORDINARILY HARD IN
PUTTING THIS.
PROPOSAL TOGETHER THE HOURS OF
WORK THAT WENT INTO THAT.
AS OF TODAY WE'VE HAD EIGHTY
THREE HEARINGS ANOTHER TOYS
DISCUSSION AS TO HOW MUCH
DELIBERATION WE HAVE AS WE PUT
TOGETHER. THIS.
BUDGET PROPOSAL BUT EIGHTY
THREE HEARINGS HOURS AND HOURS
OF TESTIMONY THAT THE PUBLIC IS
INVITED TO H. EACH AND EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THOSE AND. I GIVES
THEIR CONSISTENT AND CONSTANT
FEEDBACK EVEN NOW AS WE ARE
ENTER INTO.
BUDGET CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
SO I DO WANT ALL IN PARTICULAR
JUST RECOGNIZE THE FIVE.
BUDGET SUB SHOOTERS WITHIN AN
AMAZING JOB IN EACH OF THEIR
AREAS VERY MUCH CRAFTING
PROPOSALS WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEES TO COME UP WITH ALL
THE DIFFERENT PIECES THAT WE
HAVE PUT TOGETHER.
SO FIRST WITH A TO START OFF
WITH BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ONE
DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
IF I MAY I WANTED TO THANK THE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WITH ME FROM DOCTOR
WOULD TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO.
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS
AS WELL AS TO OUR COMMITTEE
STAFF ANDREA MARGOLIS AND THE
CALL VASQUEZ.
WE COULD NOT DO THIS WITHOUT
YOU.
pEIGHTEEN PUBLIC HEARINGS MANY
LASTING MORE THAN JUST A FEW
HOURS.
AND WE HEARD FROM PEOPLE ALL
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
ABOUT THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES NEED OF OUR GREAT
STATE.
RESPONDING TO THOSE NEEDS
OUR SOMEONE TOOK THE FOLLOWING
ACTIONS THIS YEAR.
ON THE HEALTH SIDE OF SOMEONE.
WE TURNED OUT THIS TURNED OUT TO
BE A PRECEDENT SETTING YEAR FOR
US.
ABOUT WHICH MANY OF US SHOULD
FEEL PROUD.
FIRST AND FOREMOST WE MADE A
VERY SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
HEALTH CARE.
ONE BILLION DOLLARS.
THIS INVESTMENT IS SIGNIFICANT
IN SIZE OF COURSE
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY.
IT IS SIGNIFICANT IN THAT IT
MOVES THE STATE A LONG WAY
TOWARDS UNIVERSAL COVERAGE.
AND TOWARDS OUR GOAL OF MAKING
HEALTH CARE TRULY ACCESSIBLE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS.
OUR INVESTMENTADDRESSES THE
FOLLOWING KEY CHALLENGES IN
HEALTHCARE IN CALIFORNIA.
FIRST
EXPANSION OF COVERAGE.
WE EXPAND COVERAGE IN SEVERAL
WAYS THE MOST OF SIGNIFICANT IS.
WE FIRST MAKE LOW ALL LOW INCOME
YOUNG ADULT ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDICAL.
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS.
SECOND WE INCREASE ELIGIBILITY
FOR THE AGED AND DISABLED TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT PERCENT
OF FEDERAL POVERTY.
THE SAME LEVEL IT IS FOR YOUNGER
PEOPLE.
IN TERMS OF AFFORDABILITY OF
HEALTH CARE.
DESPITE THE SUBSTANTIAL GAINS IN
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE IN REFORMS
IN OUR STATE AND NATION.
INSURANCE REMAINS ON AFFORDABLE
TO MANY MIDDLE INCOME
CALIFORNIANS.
EVEN LEADING SOME TO CHOOSE TO
BE UNINSURED.
IN SOMEONE WE INVESTED OVER HALF
A BILLION DOLLARS INTO PROVIDING
PREMIUM ASSISTANCE TO PEOPLE.
BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED AND SIX
HUNDRED PERCENT OF FEDERAL
POVERTY.
FAMILIES SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE AND HOUSING.
OR BETWEEN HEALTH CARE AND
HUNGER.
FINALLY SOMEONE'S INVESTMENT
INCLUDES THE CREATION OF AN ALL
PAYER CLAIMS DATABASE.
TO COLLECT COST DATA
MAKE IT TRANSPARENT AND LEAD US
TOWARD COST CONTROLS.
WE WOULD MAKE A SUBSTANTIAL
INVESTMENT IN OUR HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE AND UNDERSERVED
MEDICAL SHORTAGE AREAS.
OUTSIDE OF THE HEALTH CARE.
EXPANSION REFORMS SOMEONE
INVESTED FIFTY MILLION OF PROP
FIFTY SIX REVENUES INTO MEDI CAL
PROVIDER RATE INCREASES AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSIONS
FURTHER ON PROP FIFTY SIX.
FINALLY WE MADE UNPRECEDENTED
AND EXCITING INVESTMENTS IN
PUBLIC HEALTH
WITH OVER SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ON PREVENTION EFFORTS
FOR STDS.
OPIOID OVERDOSE HIV AIDS.
DIABETES HEPATITIS C. AND VALLEY
FEVER.
IT HAS BEEN AN HONOR AND A
PRIVILEGE TO LEAD THE ASSEMBLY'S
DECISION MAKING ON INVESTMENTS
IN HEALTHCARE AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
HOPEFULLY SETTING THE STAGE FOR
A HEALTHIER CALIFORNIA.
NOW ON TO HUMAN SERVICES SIDE OF
OUR WORK FOR SOMEONE.
WE APPROVED THE ELIMINATION OF
THE SSI CASH OUT FOR SS I SS P.
RECIPIENTS.
HOLDING HARMLESS THE CURRENT
CASELOAD.
WHICH WILL EXPAND FOOD BENEFITS
FOR OVER FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
S. S. P. HOUSEHOLDS.
WE BUILT UPON THE GOVERNOR'S
INITIATIVE ON THE CREATION OF A
HOME VISITING PROGRAMS FOR
PARENTS AND THEIR INFANTS AND
TODDLERS WHO WERE LIVING IN
POVERTY.
EXPANDING THE POPULATION
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE SERVICE AND
MAKING THE PROGRAM PERMANENT
WITHIN CAL WORKS.
WE KNOW THAT THIS HOME VISITING
PROGRAM CHANGES THE LIVES OF
PARTICIPATING FAMILIES FOR THE
BETTER.
WITH VITAL HEALTH AND POSITIVE
DEVELOPMENT OUTCOMES FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN.
IN THE AREA OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES WE FUNDED A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR BRIDGE PROGRAM TO
AMELIORATE FISCAL DISTRESS BEING
FELT BY DD PROVIDERS LOCATED IN
AREAS OF THE STATE WITH HIGH
LABOR COSTS.
WE PUT TWELVE POINT SIX MILLION
INTO EMERGENCY FOOD
DISTRIBUTION.
TO AID WITH HUNGER RELIEF
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND
PROVIDED TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR
SORELY NEEDED INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS AT FOOD BANKS AND
PANTRIES.
WE FUNDED THE MEALS ON WHEELS
AND CONGREGATE NUTRITION WITH AN
ADDITIONAL TEN MILLION.
AND SUSTAINED THIS AND PROVIDED
SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION FOR
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM.
WE PROVIDED ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR IMMIGRATION SERVICES WITH
PARTICULAR ATTENTION TO
RECIPIENTS OF THE TEMPORARY
pGEOGRAPHIC AREAS IN NEED OF
SERVICE CAPACITY AND DETAINEES
IN IMMIGRATION COURT.
IN THE FOSTER CARE AREA WE
PROVIDED FUNDING TO CREATE A
FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM.
TO GIVE SUPPORT AND COUNSELING
TO CAREGIVERS
AND CURRENT OR FORMER FOSTER
CHILDREN OR YOUTH AND WE
BACKFILLED A REDUCTION TO THE
VITAL FOSTER PARENT RETENTION
RECRUITMENT AND SUPPORT PROGRAM.
LASTLY WE PROVIDED MODEST
ONGOING FUNDING TO MEET THE
NEEDS IN THE DEAF ACCESS PROGRAM
AND FOR THE INDIAN HEALTH
CLINICS
AND ONE TIME SUPPORT FOR DIAPER
DISTRIBUTION. HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR
ASSISTANCE AND YOUTH AND FAMILY
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
THOSE ARE THE INVESTMENTS THAT
SOMEONE CHOSE TO TAKE.
TOWARDS
THE CRAFTING OF THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN STATE BUDGET.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE TO MISSED
MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ALSO WANT
TO START BY RECOGNIZE OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER CHAVEZ
VOEPEL. MART SUIT SHE O'DONNELL.
MEDINA AND LIMON THANK YOU.
WHEN I RECOGNIZE TO OUR STAFF.
MARK MARTIN KATIE HEARD IN MANY
CHRISTIAN GRIFFITH.
HELPED OVERSEE THINK ABOUT FORTY
HOURS OF PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
HEARING AND.
THOUGHTFUL.
CONSIDERATION OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL I'D JUST DIE NO MISTER
CHAIR YOU HIGHLIGHTED ALREADY.
THE PACKAGE IT'S WHEN I GO INTO
A FEW MORE DETAILS WILL START
WITH THE.
EARLY EDUCATION PEACE KNOWING
THAT.
.
THE BEST PLACE TO START
INVESTING IN OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM I YOU KNOW THE DOLLAR
AMOUNT NEARLY A BILLION DOLLARS
FOR EARLY EDUCATION AND AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS BUT. WHAT IS IT
ACTUALLY MEAN ABOUT?
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND NEW
CHILDCARE SLOTS FOR FAMILIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. A NOT QUITE
RESTORING THE CUTS FROM THE
GREAT RECESSION BUT.
BUT REALLY GETTING THERE.
WE INCREASED BY OVER FIVE
THOUSAND.
PRESCHOOL SLOTS FULL DAY
PRESCHOOL SLOTS TO TO HELP.
WORKING FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA
I'VE NOTES.
WE'RE DOING A PILOT TO ALLOW
AND MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES WHO
AREN'T QUITE.
INCOME ELIGIBLE AND TO
PARTICIPATE IN TITLE ONE SCHOOLS
AND WE'RE ALSO MAKING SURE WE
ADDRESS INFANT AND TODDLER
ISSUES TO MAKE SURE THOSE
PROGRAMS CAN THRIVE AS WELL AS
DEALING WITH OUR SPECIAL NEEDS.
FACILITIES IS A BIG ISSUE WE
HEARD FROM OUR PRE K. AND.
* CHILDCARE PROGRAMS HAVE A
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR BLOCK
GRANT TO HELP ADDRESS FACILITY
NEEDS. WE ALSO MAKE OTHER
CHANGES TO REDUCE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDENS
HOW TO ALLOW FOR BRAIDING OF THE
PRE K. PROGRAMS AND STATE
PRESCHOOL AS WELL AS OUR T. CARE
PROGRAMS THROUGH OUR LOCAL
AFFILIATES SO. EASY.
HAVE A ROBUST PACKAGE HERE AS
FAR AS THE HIGHER EDUCATION YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER I FULLY
FUNDING THAT YOU SEE IN CSU.
PACKAGES THAT WILL NOTE FOR THE.
FOR THE CSU AT OUR ALLOW US TO
THE ROLE OVER ELEVEN THOUSAND
MORE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WHO
ARE.
ELIGIBLE BUT TOO OFTEN DENIED
ACCESS TO THE CSU ALSO ALLOWS TO
HAVE FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
ADDRESS A FULL TIME FACULTY IN
THE CSU PROGRAM.
AS WELL AS INCREASING ACCESS
PER PROGRAMS LIKE.
HUNGER AND.
AND HOUSING CRISIS THAT ARE AT
OUR CAMPUSES THROUGHOUT THE CSU
SYSTEM. FOR YOU SEE HOW YOU DID
NOTE THAT WE PROVIDE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN MILLION ABOVE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO FUND THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. A
FULLY FUNDING THE YOU SEE.
BUDGET REQUESTS.
ACTUALLY WE GO A LITTLE BIT
ABOVE THAT TO TO MAKE SURE WE
FOCUS ON. ENROLLMENT AT WE IT WE
ALLOW TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED MORE
QUALIFIED CALIFORNIANS TO HAVE
ACCESS AT THE UC.
THINK THAT'S CRITICAL KNOWING
HOW MANY OF OUR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS ARE ARE ARE PREPARED
READY TO GO TO THE.
.
TO THE.
UC SYSTEM IN OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THE ROBUST PROP NINETY
EIGHT PACKETS ALLOWS US TO.
GIVE THE COMMITTEE COLLEGE IS A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN FUNDING
TO HIGH PROFILE PROPOSALS TO IT
TO NOTE WE DID I REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S ONLINE. A
COMMUNICABLE PROPOSAL KNOW THAT
WOULD PROBABLY HAVE DISCUSSION
THAT THROUGHOUT CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS A NEW
FUNDING FORMULA. WE ADDRESS THE
CONCEPT IN PRINCIPLE BUT WE ASK
THAT BUT WE DID REJECT AS WELL
AS THE CHANCES OFFICE TO GO BACK
AND WORK THROUGH A STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS.
TO.
TO MAKE SURE THAT COMES BACK IN
THE NEXT BUDGET YEAR A LITTLE
BIT MORE.
THOUGH THE MORE I PREPARED.
.
AS FAR AS OUR PROP NINETY EIGHT
PACKAGE.
THIS SO THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
UP PLUS OUR SUBCOMMITTEE ACTION
ALLOWS US TO FULLY FUND THE LCF
THAT.
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING BASE
FUNDING AT ABOUT THREE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
AGAIN.
FULLY IMPLEMENTING THE LCF AFT
PROGRAM AHEAD OF SCHEDULE OUR
PROPOSAL IS THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ABOVE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED LEVEL FOR
LOCAL.
FUNDING FOR OUR SCHOOLS.
WE ALSO MAKE SURE THAT WE THAT
WE REALIZE IT DOESN'T DEAL WITH
ALL OF OUR SCHOOL.
DOT FINANCIAL ISSUES AND WHIRLS
WHERE HERE'S HIM LOUD AND CLEAR
FROM OUR LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT WE FOCUS ON INTENT TO
INCREASE THE ELSE IF AT. ALL
BASE RATES BEGINNING IN TWENTY
AND NINETEEN TWENTY. WE DO PUT
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION TO
CREATE A NEW SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT
FOR LOWEST PERFORMING A SUBGROUP
IN OUR CALIFORNIA'S SCHOOLS
REALLY DEALING WITH THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP. WE HAVE NEARLY
HALF A BILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME MONEY FOR DISCRETIONARY.
BIPARTISAN PUSH ALL YEAR WAS
RCT  PROGRAMS ARE PROUD
THAT WE HAD DOUBLED FUNDING FOR
A SEAT CT INCENTIVE GRANT
PROGRAM AS WELL AS KEPT THE
ADMINISTRATION DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WHICH WAS WHAT.
STAKEHOLDERS WELLS A LEGISLATORS
AND SPOKE ABOUT.
WE HAD A BIG HEARING THIS YEAR
WITH WITH OUR K. TWELVE
COMMITTEE ON SPECIAL EDUCATION.
AND WE'RE ABLE TO PROVIDE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TOWARDS
EQUALIZING FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN I KNOW
THAT'S AN ISSUE BEEN TRYING TO
TALK WITH THE LAST FEW YEARS WE
FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO HELP DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
INCENTIVIZE MORE FULL DAY CUT
KINDERGARTEN. FOR OUR STATE
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS THEY'VE
BEEN DEALING WITH THE IMPACTS OF
THE MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES AND.
AND STRAINING THEIR BY JUSTICE
TO SERVE MORE STUDENTS AND
PROVIDE THEM WITH SEVENTY SIX
MILLION. TO US TO BOLSTER OUR
STATE AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
NOW WE ALSO WORK ON OUR TEACHER
PROGRAMS HELPING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TRAINING RECRUITS.
MORE TEACHERS.
THAT'S A SNAPSHOT OF OUR ARE
SAID TO PLAN MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR. FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AS WELL
I THINK IT WAS MCCARTY.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
THREE MISTER BLOW.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR SERVICE
TO ALL OF OUR SUBCOMMITTEES.
.
I WANTED TO.
I SAY THANK YOU TO ALL THE
MEMBERS OF MY SUBCOMMITTEE
FOLLOWING GOTTA. BUILD LEAD OF
MY FELLOW SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIR SO.
MISTER FONG PATTERSON MULLIN
AND KALRA THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE MANY MANY HOURS OF
EFFORT THAT YOU PUT IN ON.
ATTENDING MEETINGS AND STUNNING
THIS BUDGET AND BRING US TO A.
CONCLUSION JUST A.
A FEW.
.
ONLY FEW DAYS AGO.
AM I WANNA THANK OUT OF MY
BUDGET STAFF OF.
SUSAN CHAN IN FARAH BRACT.
BUT REALLY WANT TAKE ALL THE
BUDGET STAFF BECAUSE BUT JUST
HAVE REALLY WORKS
COLLABORATIVELY.
AND INSURES THAT WE HAVE A. A A
VERY SMOOTH PROCESS EVERY YEAR
AND THAT'S BEEN MY EXPERIENCE
YEAR AFTER YEAR SO I WANT TO
THANK. ALL OF YOU THAT HELP MAKE
THAT HAPPEN IN THAT INCLUDES THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WHICH SHOW A. DUTIFULLY SHOWS UP
IN EVERY MEETING AND PROVIDES US
WITH INSIGHT.
I AND TO ASSISTANCE AND
CRAFTING THE BUDGET. AND TO EVEN
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
HELPS US AND WE GOT A SMILE
THERE.
WE.
YOU KNOW WE.
IT'S HELPFUL TO A TO SIT AND BE
ABLE TO ASK QUESTIONS AND PARRY
BACK AND FORTH AND THAT'S REALLY
WHAT THE PROCESS IS ALL ABOUT.
SO THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR HARD
WORK AND MAKING THE PROCESS
COLLABORATIVE AND PRODUCTIVE AND
EVEN FUN ON A COUPLE OF
OCCASIONS WE HAD IT RIGHT A
COUPLE MOMENTS DID WE NOT.
BUT.
NOW.
GETTING DOWN TO BRASS TACKS AND
WHAT WE ACCOMPLISHED AND.
SUBCOMMITTEE THREE IT WAS.
WAS A GOOD DEAL AND AFTER THE
HORRIFIC FIRES IN SUING FLOODS
THAT DEVASTATED COMMUNITIES FROM
NORTHERN TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
FIRE RELATED INVESTMENTS RIGHT
FULLY HEADLINE THE COMMITTEE'S
WORK THIS YEAR. AND WE'VE FTA
ADDED MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
OUR EXISTING FIRE PREVENTION AND
RESPONSE EFFORTS WHICH WERE
ALREADY PRETTY ROBUST.
.
WE ADDED TO OF THOSE DOLLARS IN
THE SUB COMMITTEE THIS YEAR
IMPROVING PUBLIC HEALTH AND SOME
OF OUR MOST DISADVANTAGED.
COMMUNITIES IS ANOTHER LARGE
AREA OF FOCUS FOR THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND WE INVESTED
OVER THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO IMPROVE AIR
QUALITY PERCENT EIGHTY. AB SIX
SEVENTEEN AND TO INCREASE ACCESS
TO CLEAN DRINKING WATER ON THAT.
DRINKING WATER ISSUE IN
PARTICULAR I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSCORE THAT
WERE REALLY.
STILL NOT CLOSE TO WHERE WE
NEED TO BE.
OTHER CONDITIONS THAT A NUMBER
OF CALIFORNIANS
LIVE AND.
IS NOW ON A DAILY BASIS IS
REALLY APPALLING. AND I BELIEVE
THE GENERAL AT THE JOB GENERAL
PUBLIC. OF THAT NEW THIS WAS
HAPPENING THEY BE EQUALLY
APPALLED AT OUR INABILITY AS AN
INSTITUTION TO RIGHT THIS WRONG.
SO I'M HOPEFUL THAT IS WE HAD A
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE WE'RE GOING
TO FIND A SOLUTION THAT HAS SO
FAR HAS HAS BEEN ELUSIVE.
BUT A SOLUTION THAT WORKS FOR
EVERYONE. AS BEST AS POSSIBLE.
UP
WE'VE ALSO INVESTED OVER THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
IMPROVE THE HEALTH.
AND CLIMATE RESILIENCY OF OUR
FORESTS WETLANDS AND COASTAL
ZONES AS WELL AS CONTINUING TO
PRIORITIZE URBAN GREENING AND
URBAN FORESTRY.
SUB THREE IS ALSO RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE AREAS OF ENERGY AND
TRANSPORTATION. AND IN THOSE
AREAS WE APPROVED A CAP AND
TRADE.
EXPENDITURE PLAN OF ABOUT ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
THAT IN ADDITION TO CLEAN AIR
WATER NATURAL LANDS IN URBAN
GRADING INVENTS A INVESTMENTS
MENTIONED ABOVE. INCLUDES AROUND
SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
CLEAN VEHICLES TRUCKS BUSES
FREIGHT.
AND HEAVY DUTY EQUIPMENT.
AND WE CONTINUED OUR COMMITMENT
INVESTMENT.
IN THE TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM.
LA WHICH PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
WASTE DIVERSION TO HELP ME S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE EMISSIONS
GOALS.
FUNDING FOR PORTS SUCH A SAN
DIEGO AND MONEY FOR LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION AND LAST BUT NOT
LEAST WE ALSO ADOPTED A STRATEGY
FOR ZERO. AND NEAR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES AND RELATED CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE THIS FRAMEWORK.
WILL HELP TO ENSURE THAT THE
GOAL OF FIVE MILLION ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES BY TWENTY
THIRTY BECOMES A REALITY.
THANK YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FOR
MISTER COOPER.
GOOD EVENING OF FIRST LOVE LIKE
THINK A CHURCH.
SHOOTING FELIZ HELP.
ONCE OP THING MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE FOR WITH CAVIAR OF.
CHIU DOCTOR CHOI MISTER BROKE
THE DEDICATION TO THE WORK WE DO
THEIR SUBCOMMITTEE
SUB FOR COVER A WIDE RANGE OF
ISSUES THIS YEAR. INCREASED
INVESTMENT OUR KEY PRIORITIES WE
TWELVE HEARINGS AND ONE THING
STAFF JV FARAH CHRISTIAN. AND
ROY WHO WORKS FOR ME A SOMEHOW
LIGHTS THAT MISTER ROUTINE
COVERED ALREADY THOUGH YOU SEE
THE ONE POINT FIVE BILLION FOR
MERCY HOUSING. HOMELESS EIGHT
AGO IT'S A LONG WAYS.
PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR CAL WORKS
HOMES AND HOUSING SUPPORTS AND
CHANGED LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDIT CAP.
WE SPEND THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT COVER WORKING FAMILIES
WHO ARE AGED EIGHTEEN TWENTY
FOUR IN OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY
FIVE. INCLUDING WORKING
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES WITH FAIRLY
ASSIGNED INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER ID
NUMBERS OR SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS AND INCREASE THE
QUALIFYING INCOME RANGE FOR
CREDITS.
WE ALSO PRETTY TOTAL OF ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE MILLION FOR
CANNABIS RELATED ACTIVITIES FREE
TWO YEAR TERM BASIS.
WE PROVED TO PROGRAMS TO FOCUS
ON THE FORCE MAIN ISSUES
FOR CANNABIS INCLUDING FOURTEEN
MILLION. DEPARTMENT JUSTICE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR THREE
YEAR GRANT PROGRAM FOR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS.
I COMMITTEE ADOPT A FIVE YEAR
EXTENSION OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMPETES PROGRAM IMPROVE TWENTY
MILLION FOR FIVE YEARS FOR THE
SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT.
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE EXPANSION
PROGRAM.
WE ALSO AUTHORIZED ADDITIONAL
THREE MILLION TO BE DEDICATED TO
SMALL BUSINESSES
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTERS
INCLUDING. BUT NOT LIMITED TO
WOMEN'S AND VETERANS BUSINESSES.
OUR WORK ALSO HAD ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS
COMPLETE COUNT. OUT REACH
ACTIVITIES OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS THIS INVESTMENT IS
CRITICAL TO MAKE SURE ALL
CALIFORNIANS ARE COUNTED NATION
SENSES THE STATE OF THE FEDERAL
FUNDING. IT ROUGHLY DESERVES.
WE PROVED HER THIRTY FOUR
MILLION TO HELP ON THE
REPLACEMENT OF COUNTY VOTING
SYSTEMS.
THE SYSTEMS ARE OUTDATED AND
NEED TO BE REPLACED TO ENSURE
THE INTEGRITY OF OUR VOTING
SYSTEM.
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR HARDWARE
SOFTWARE LICENSES IMPROVE FEELS.
ALSO SIMPLY ADOPTED TURN ABILITY
WHICH TO GUIDE THE EXPENDITURE
OF THESE FUNDS.
AND FINALLY OUR COMMITTEE
APPROVED SEVEN POINT ONE MILLION
GENERAL FUND THE PERFORMANCE
CRITERIA PHASE EVERY NEW SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY AT OUR VETERANS
HOMES OF CALIFORNIA YEAH FILL.
SILLY REPLACE THE OUTDATED HIM
VERY COSTLY TO MAINTAIN.
FACILITY A HEALTH BILL THAT
INCLUDES SOME FORCE REPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER OF THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FIVE
DR WEBER YES THANK YOU.
.
MISTER CHAIR AND OUR VICE CHAIR
FOR IT FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
SUPPORT DURING THIS PROCESS ONE
THANK MY COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
MISS MELINDA'S MISTER LACKEY
MISTER JONES SAWYER AND MRS
STONE FOR THEIR HARD WORK BEING
PRESENT. AND IT WAS DIFFICULT
BECAUSE MOST OF WASN'T TOO IN
PRE MEETINGS AT ONE TIME AND SO
I WANT TO THANK THEM FOR THAT
AND THANK MISTER OBERNOLTE FOR
SITTING AND AT TIMES. WHEN
MEMBERS WERE NOT BEER SO IN
ORDER FOR US TO KEEP OF THE
AGENDA GOING FORWARD. WANT TO
THANK MY.
JENNIFER KIM THE CONSULTANTS IF
THIS WAS OUR FIRST TIME AT THE
BUDGET YOU DID A FANTASTIC JOB.
OF OF TAKING US ALL THROUGH THE
PROCESS AND KEEPING US FOCUSED.
YOU KNOW THIS IS PROBABLY THE
FIRST TIME.
IN THE THIS IS MY SIX YEAR
BEING GIVE THE PRO FIRST TIME OF
THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE SOME DISMAL
NEWS ABOUT HOW WE WERE
INCREASING THE PRISON
POPULATION.
AND HOW WAS GROWING BEYOND
CONTROL.
WE SAW FOR THE FIRST TIME THAT
TO WE HAD A REDUCTION OF ALMOST
THIRTY THOUSAND PEOPLE IN OUR
PRISONS.
AND WHICH IS A GREAT THINGS
ABOUT THE QUESTION BECOMES HOW
WOULD WE DO ABOUT IT AND HOW TO
USE THE FACILITIES THAT OF
THEIR.
FOR THE FIRST TIME WE WERE ABLE
TO REALLY GET IN DEPTH IN TERMS
OF FUNDING OUR COURTS THIS YEAR.
WE'VE APPROVED NEARLY FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING FOR
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH A WHICH
INCLUDES NOT ONLY FUNDING COURT
REPORTERS IN THE AREA FOR FAMILY
COURT PROCEEDINGS THAT WE FELT
WAS SO DESPERATELY. NEEDED TO TO
ENSURE JUSTICE BUT ALSO SUPPORT
EQUAL ACCESS FUND FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES WE COULD FIND SOME
JUDGES SOME IMPROVEMENTS AND
SOME OF THE COURTS THAT WERE
HERE. WE'VE ALSO PROVED ONE
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
LEASE REVENUE BONDS FOR COURT
CONSTRUCTION. OF WE HAD AN OLD
LIST OF COURT CONSTRUCTION AND
SO WE'VE APPROVED THE AMOUNT BUT
IT BUT BASICALLY LEFT OPEN FOR
US IN IN TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
HA HA AN ASSESSMENT OF HOW WHAT
WE WILL DEAL WITH THE MONEY.
WEEK MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
THINGS ON THE LIST OF STILL
THINKS OF HIGH PRIORITY.
WE'VE ALSO PROVED A TOTAL OF
FIFTY MILLION TO ADDRESS THE
EFFECTS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT BY SUPPORTING AGENCIES.
THAT PROVIDE SERVICES TO
SURVIVORS OF THIS IS ON TOP OF
WHAT WE'VE BEEN FUNDING ALL
ALONG THE TREMENDOUS SPEED THIS
THEIR.
.
WE HAVE FUNDS FOR IMPROVING LAW
ENFORCEMENT ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
WAS FUN AT FIRST TIMES WE'VE
ACTUALLY GIVEN ADDITIONAL MONEY
TO POST
AND THIS IS DESIGNED TO HELP LAW
ENFORCEMENT PRIORITIZE THAT WITH
OF THE TRAINING FOR POLICE
OFFICERS.
TO USE TOOLS NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF FORCE AND
LEARN THE ESCALATION STRATEGIES
AND TECHNIQUES TO SUPPORT OUR AT
ALSO SUPPORT FOR OFFICERS
WELLNESS WE'VE. LOOKED AT
INFORMATION CONCERNING OF THE
HAVES IT'S REALLY OF BEING AN
OFFICER BETWEEN TERMS OF YOUR
PHYSICAL CONDITION MENTAL
CONDITION AND THE AND THE TOLL
IT TAKES SOMEONE'S FAMILY. SO WE
FUNDED TO WE'VE PUT IN SOME
ADDITIONAL MONEY ON TOP OF WHAT
POST ALREADY HAS TO ASSIST IN
THE TRAINING THAT'S THERE. ARE
IN THAT WE ALSO CREATED A FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR GRANT PROGRAM
WHICH ALLOWS SOME INNOVATION AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL IS TO APPLY FOR
SO THEY COULD ALSO BE INVOLVED
IN. THEIR TRADING AND OUT WE
FEEL THAT THE KEY TO WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO TRY TO ACCOMPLISH IN
TERMS OF CREATING A SAFER
CALIFORNIA EVERY COMMUNITY IS
GOING TO BE INVOLVED. A WITH THE
ISSUE OF TRAINING AND
DEVELOPMENT AND AND STAFF
DEVELOPMENT AND SUPPORT FOR
OFFICERS.
YEAR TO YEAR AS I POINTED OUT
BEFORE WE'VE HAD DIFFICULTY
DEALING WITH THE ISSUE OF
CORRECTIONS IN TERMS OF COSTLY
PUTTING MORE AND MORE MONEY.
INTO CORRECTION SOME OF YOU MAY
REMEMBER ONE YEAR WE HAD TO PUT
AN ADDITIONAL THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN ON TOP
OF IT BECAUSE OF THE
OVERCROWDING. SITUATION IN OUR
PRISONS ARE WHAT WE'VE WHAT
WE'RE DOING NOW IS OF COURSE
WITH THE MONEY THAT'S AVAILABLE
WE'RE FINALLY GETTING TO THE
POINT WE CAN FIX OUR ROADS.
WE'RE LOOKING AT REPLACING
KITCHENS AND BORIS AND THINGS
THAT WOULD NOT FUNCTIONAL NOT
WORKING THAT WELL AND SAFE.
WE WILL ALSO BE BECAUSE OF THE
THE.
REDUCTION IMPROVE IN IN THE IN
IN OUR POPULATION IN MAY
POPULATION WE'RE LOOKING AT OF
THE REQUEST HAS BEEN TO TAKE
MANY OF THE OF THE EL.
BEDDING AREAS OF THE THE HOUSING
AREAS AND TURN THEM IN THE
CLASSROOMS.
AND BECAUSE LAST YEAR WE DID WE
FIND IT.
MORE CT  IN AN EDUCATIONAL
TRAINING FOR THOSE WHO
INCARCERATED OF THIS YEAR WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS BUILDING OUT
CLASSROOMS IN THOSE SPACES THAT
WOULD NORMALLY HOUSE INDIVIDUALS
SO YOU DO A BETTER JOB OF CT IN
TRAINING. GETTING SOME OF THE
BETTER.
THE MOST UP TO DATE TECHNOLOGY
THAT SEVERE SO EVEN THOUGH WE
SEE THIS THIS SUB DECREE
DECREASE IN. THE POPULATION WE
REALIZE THAT THE. DOESN'T
NECESSARILY TRANSLATE WE SEE IN
TO FUNDING IN TERMS OF SAVINGS
BECAUSE OF THE SOME BECAUSE OF
THE PROGRAM SO OFTEN BUT ALSO
BECAUSE THAT WHAT IS REQUIRED TO
STAFF THE PRISONS OUT OF THERE.
OF WHAT WE'VE DONE THOUGH IS
BECAUSE WE REALIZE AT SOME POINT
WE WILL GET TO THIS POINT WHERE
WE WILL BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY SHUT
DOWN A PRISON SOMEWHERE WHAT TO
REPURPOSE A FACILITY. ALL WE'VE
ASKED THE DEPARTMENT ITSELF TO
CREATE A LONG TERM PLAN ON HOW
THEY CAN INVEST RESOURCES IN AND
DODD THAT'S THERE ARE LONG TERM
FACILITIES PLANNED BUTTE TO
RESPOND. TO THE DECLINING
POPULATION.
WITH DEALING WITH A JUVENILE
JUSTICE DIVERSION PROGRAM.
WE ARE INVESTING A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AND IN KIDS IN
THE STATE TO TO COULD LOVE WHO
COMMITS US STATUS OFFENSES AND
MISDEMEANORS AWAY FROM THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM INTO
TRAUMA INFORMED SERVICES. BACK
IN IN THAT CAN INTERRUPT THE
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE OF THE
PROPOSAL PROVIDE SOCIAL WORKERS
TO IN MOST UP PUBLIC DEFENDERS
OFFICES.
SPECIALIZE ON DIVERSION PROGRAM
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE AND ALSO
SPECIALIZE IN DIVERSION PROGRAM
FOR NATIVE AMERICAN YOUTH WHO WE
SEE HAVE ONE OF THE HIGHEST DROP
OUT RATES OF ANY GROUP IN THIS
NATION.
WE ARE LOOKING AT.
WE HOPE THAT THAT MORE THAN
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND PRIMARY USE
OF COLORS WOULD BE POSITIVELY
IMPACTED BY THIS HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT.
SO WE WERE ABLE TO DO SOME
THINGS WE ALWAYS TALKED ABOUT
BEFORE IN TERMS OF PUBLIC SAFETY
WE WERE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THOSE
THINGS SO I THINK THE STAFF
WORKING VERY HARD ON IT YOU SEE
THE LIST OF OF. A NUMBER OF
PROPOSALS THAT HAVE COME FORWARD
AND A NUMBER OF.
RECOMMENDATIONS AND PROPOSALS
THAT CAME FROM MEMBERS OF ONE OF
THINK I CHEERED VICE CHAIR FOR
THE LEADERSHIP BUT. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WEBER AYE LET ME AGAIN
JUST ALSO.
ECHOED THE THANKS FOR OUR OUR
ENTIRE.
BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFF WHO WORK
TIRELESSLY FOR BOTH BOTH SIDES
OF THE AISLE WOULD HAVE DONE A
REALLY FABULOUS JOB LET ME ALSO
JUST THINK ARE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST. AND THEIR OFFICE THAT
HAS PUT IN HOURS AND HOURS AND
HOURS IN EACH OF THESE THE ISSUE
AREAS REALLY HELP PROVIDING US
INFORMATION AND GUIDANCE DURING
THAT PROCESS. I ALSO WANTED.
I'M A FINANCE FOR ALL OF THEIR
HOURS OF WORK IN THIS BUDGET
PROCESS AND ALL THE.
FULL PARTICIPATION ON THE
COMMITTEE HERE IT'S BEEN
ABSOLUTE CRITICAL TO HAVE THEM
AT THE TABLE IMAGES THANK ALSO
ARE ASSEMBLY SERGEANTS WHO DO A
GREAT JOB STAFFING. AND ALL THE
COMMITTEES AND REALLY MAKING
SURE THAT NOTHING'S RUN VERY
SMOOTHLY SO JUST THANK YOU TO
THE STAFF. UP WITH THAT LET ME
JUST BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IS.
HAVE COMMITTEE AYE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS AND THAT THEY COULD
TRUST THEM DIRECTLY TO HOW YOU
KNOW AS WELL AS WELL AS DODD
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. MR
MEDINA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I. JUST
WANT TO.
.
THANK PERSONALLY.
SUB CHAIRED TO MR MCCARTY.
AND ARE CHAIRED THE FULL BUDGET.
MISTER TING.
FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP. AND FOR
SUB TO FOR HIGHER EDUCATION.
OF FOR A BUDGET THAT I THINK ALL
CALIFORNIANS CAN BE PROUD OF. AS
IT RELATES TO HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND TO SAY THAT.
WE HEARD TIME AND TIME AGAIN
FROM THE STUDENTS FACULTY
ADMINISTRATION. AND THAT THIS.
BUDGET THIS YEAR IS SOMETHING
THAT THE HOSTED A CALIFORNIA CAN
BE PROUD OF. AND I THINK THAT
OUR VICE CHAIR AND I'M SURE.
THANK YOU WAS MEDINA.
WELL I'VE NEVER SEEN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE THIS QUIET BEFORE THIS
IS A HISTORIC MOMENT.
WELL WHAT HAVE WE ARE YOU KNOW
WHAT WE'RE GONNA HOLD ALL
COMMITTEE HEARINGS TO SEVEN PM
FROM NOW ON.
MISS RUBIO.
YES THANK YOU I WOULD LIKE TO
ALSO THINK I HAVE A COMMITTEE
STAFFS ALL THE COMMITTEES I KNOW
HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO.
ME THERE FOR HOURS AND HOURS
AND HOURS. ON WANT TO THANK OUR
CHAIR BY DOCTOR ARAMBULA FOR. A.
SPENDING SO MUCH TIME AND
ENERGY.
ON MAKING THAT.
THE I HUMAN HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES PRIORITIES.
.
UP PRIORITY FOR OUR COMMITTEE
BUT I ALSO AM CHAIR OF HUMAN
SERVICES AND WANTED TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR VISION AND. TRYING TO.
HELP BILLS MOST VULNERABLE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND I REALLY
THE OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MR MATHESON MISTER HARPER I KNOW
WE DON'T ALWAYS SEE IT UP TO AYE
BUT I THINK WE.
CAME AS CLOSE.
AS WE COULD TO HAVE A
BIPARTISAN AYE DIALOGUE IN EVERY
ISSUE AND SO I REALLY APPRECIATE
A WORKING WITH YOU.
AS WELL AS DOCTOR WOULD SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISS OUR RUBIO.
AND SO CHáVEZ.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR
OF THE SUB.
TO COMMITTEE FOR BEEN VERY OPEN
AND WORKING WITH THE REPUBLICANS
ON THIS
WE HAD A LOT A GOOD GOOD
DISCUSSIONS AND I THINK.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT SUB TO THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY WOULD YOU KNOW
WHAT THE IMPACT ON THE STATE.
AND WE HAD A LOT OF GOOD
BIPARTISAN ISSUES I JUST LIKE
PUBLIC THANKED THE.
CHAIR OF EDUCATION.
THEY ARE.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE OUR
STAFF REPUBLIC STAFF AL.
ELENA CHRISTIANITY IN AND KATIE
SPARROW FOR THEIR WORK THE.
DO A GREAT JOB KEEPING US OUT
OF TROUBLE.
AND.
.
IN REGARDLESS OF WHAT.
MAYBE SAID ABOUT ME.
VOTING FOR BUDGETS AND THINGS
ACROSS THE STATE.
I WOULD JOB.
I DO THINK SAID TO FOR ALL THE
GREAT THINGS WE DID FOR LOCAL
FUNDING CD  PROGRAMS.
WHAT WE'RE DOING FOR TUITION
INCREASE FOR UC'S STUDENTS AND
ENROLLMENT?
THERE ARE SOME THINGS I THINK
WAS STILL NEED TO WORK ON THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FUNDING.
BUT YOU KNOW THE HOUSING CRISIS.
A RESTORED PUBLIC SAFETY
FUNDING.
IT'S EMISSIONS AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
.
BUT THOSE ISSUES I LOOK FORWARD
TO BE WORKING ON THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE TO BE MY FIRST TIME TO
DO THAT AND I LOOK FORWARD TO.
REACHED ACROSS GILES REGARDLESS
OF WHAT COMES OUT WATCHING EASY.
TO TAKE CARE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DO THE BEST THINKS.
I BUT I WILL LE.
BE HOLDING MY.
YES VOTE FOR THIS UNTIL AFTER
THE CONFERENCE.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT.
LATER ON THE MUCH.
GREAT THANK YOU MS CHAVEZ.
.
SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS PLEASE
COSTA DID YOU HAVE ANY COMMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN STERN
VICE CHAIR MEMBERS IN THE COST
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WE WOULD LIKE TO CAUTION.
AGAINST THE ARCHITECTURE OF THE
ASSEMBLIES PROPOSED BUDGET
MOSTLY ON THE REVENUE FORECAST
SIDE OF THE EQUATION.
THE BUDGET PROPOSED BEFORE YOU
UTILIZES THE ALEJO REVENUES WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF THE CORPORATION
TAX REVENUES AND THE IMPACT OF
THAT IS THAT THE REVENUES OR TWO
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
ABOVE THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION.
PROPOSAL. OFFER A VARIETY OF
REASONS WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THESE REVENUE PROJECTION SHOULD
BE ADOPTED AS PART OF THE
BUDGET.
MUCH OF THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
OUR BUDGET.
AYE AYE PARDON ME ARE REVENUE
FORECAST IN THE ANALYST AND HAVE
TO DO WITH THE PERSONAL INCOME
TAX AND CAPITAL GAINS BOTH OF
WHICH ARE VERY DIFFICULT TO
PREDICT AN EXTREMELY VOLATILE.
ON THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
ALEJO REVENUE FORECASTS ARE
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT THEY BOTH
ARE ACTUALLY PRESUMING CONTINUED
ECONOMIC GROWTH.
ALTHOUGH THE ADMINISTRATION'S
AT A SLOWER CLIP
I AM EVEN THAT HAS SOME OF US
NERVOUS A WE ARE REACHING.
THE POINT OF OUR ECONOMIC
EXPANSION BEING ONE OF THE
LONGEST IN HISTORY. AND AS SUCH
WE THINK ON THAT THERE ARE MANY
RISKS ON THE HORIZON.
THE LA OH FORECAST RELIES ON THE
GROWTH RATES THAT ARE OUTSIDE OF
HISTORIC AVERAGES.
THEIR SEEMING HIGHER GROWTH
RATES IN WAGES PARTICULARLY
PARTICULARLY IN TWENTY NINETEEN
WITH THE GROWTH RATE OF SIX
POINT SEVEN PERCENT WHICH WOULD
BE TO
PERCENT ANA ABOVE FINANCES AND
ABOVE WHAT WE'VE SEEN
HISTORICALLY.
BOTH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
ALEJO ARE ASSUMING ROBUST GROWTH
AND CAP GAINS IN A FOR TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THAT WOULD BE A TWENTY
PERCENT GROWTH FACTOR FOR
FINANCE AND THIRTY SIX PERCENT
FOR THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
ON THE LA OF CAPITAL GAINS IS
HIGHER THAN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S.
IN SEVENTEEN AND EIGHTEEN AT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY BILLION AND A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY BILLION.
VERSUS FINANCES ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE BILLION AND ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY BILLION.
FOR CONTACTS OTHER CAPITAL GAINS
ON THE LAST REPORTED LEVEL I.
HIGHEST LEVEL AND TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN WITH A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
TWO BILLION SO THAT GIVES YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF CONTACTS ABOUT THE
GROWTH. THAT FRANKLY WERE BOTH
PROJECTING.
THE LA US GROWTH ASSUMPTION FROM
POINT IT AND BREAK LATE WAGES
WILL MORE LIKELY LEAD TO
IMBALANCES AND RAISE THE RISK OF
RECESSION IN FUTURE YEARS.
LASTLY WE VIEW MUCH OF THE
GROWTH THAT WE'RE SEEING IN CAP
GAINS IN THE PERSONAL INCOME
TAXES ONE TIME IN NATURE A
DRIVEN IN PART BY THE FEDERAL
TAX REFORM ON PEOPLE GETTING
BONUSES AND CASHING OUT THINGS
THAT WE DON'T THINK WE'LL AYE
EQUATE INTO A TREND LINE LONG.
TERM.
I WE WOULD NOTE THAT A WE
SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLIES.
PROPOSAL TO ADOPT
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
FULLY FUND THE RAINY DAY FUND OF
WE'VE OFTEN TESTIFIED ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROTECTING AGAINST
THE NEXT RECESSION AND. ONE KEY
TOOL IS TO FULLY FUND THE RAINY
DAY FUND.
WE BELIEVE THAT A ROBUST
RESERVE COUPLED WITH LIMITED
ONGOING EXPENDITURES WILL BE THE
KEY TO WEATHERING THE NEXT.
RECESSION THAT WILL INEVITABLY
HIT THE STATE.
A NEW ON GOING SPENDING FOR
EXAMPLE AN EXPANDED HEALTH CARE
ACCESS WILL CREATE ADDITIONAL
PRESSURES FOR THE STATE OUT WHEN
WE ARE FACED WITH THE RECESSION
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISS COSTA.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS COULD I ASK
FOR A MOTION AND A SECOND TO
APPROVED BUDGET SOME.
SECOND THANK YOU ARE WE'RE VERY
MUCH LOOKING FORWARD TO HAVING
MORE ROBUST DISCUSSION IN OUR
BUDGET CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
WITH.
ON THIS BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT
AS WELL AS OURS I FIND SENATE
COUNTERPARTS.
AND WITH THAT. MADAM SECRETARY
TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
TING AYE. TING AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA
AYE BLOOM. BLOOM I THROW NO
THROW NO KABIRA.
CLEAR AYE CHAVIS.
CHAVEZ NOT VOTING CHIU.
CHIU AYE CHOI NOW CHOI NO
COOPER.
COOPER I FONG.
FONG NO HARPER.
HARPER NO JONES SAWYER KALRA.
KALRA KILEY LACKEY. LACKEY NOEL
LIMON.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
NOW VOTING MATHIS NOT VOTING
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA. MEDINA AYE
MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NO MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE MURATSUCHI O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO RUBIO.
STONE.
STONE AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NO WEBER.
WEBER I WOULD.
WOULD I.
I FIFTEEN KNOWS NINE NOT VOTING
TO
GIRL.
HERE.
THANK YOU THINK
.
ALL.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND MOTION
APPROVAL OF THIS SYMBOL ASSEMBLY
BUDGET.
THESE THAT WE BUDGET COMMITTEE
IS NOW ADJOURNED